for a few years now the TV show American
Pickers has been running around the
United States digging up little pieces
of history learning fun stories and
spinning them into cash but who are
these representatives of the picking art
and what were they like before they
started karting cameras everywhere Mike
Wolfe lead picker Mike Wolfe was born on
June 11th 1964 in Bettendorf Iowa not
far away from Leclaire where it needs
some day start his flagship business he
was ticking almost straight out of
diapers had been repaired and flits a
bicycle he found lying around his
neighborhood at the age of 6 for $5.00
of princely sum for a little kid not
only that it was the chalice to his
dream job so much so that he has worked
on a book specifically aimed to teach
the art of picking two kids also
ingrained in him from childhood was a
long-running interest in bikes in the
90s he owned two biking stores and
competed in races and his ventures into
professional picking started with quests
for old bikes
however the allure of picking grew too
strong for Mike and he felt the road
calling so he bought a van and really
got into it a few road trips later
somebody suggested tools that he should
take along a video camera and his friend
Frank Fritz started joining in as well
the fair made a lot of home movies and
pitches over four years before the
History Channel bit debate and green
light of the show Frank Fritz
next we shift the spotlight to Mike
Wolfe childhood friend since middle
school Frank Fritz
he was born on October 11th 1965 in
Davenport Iowa most of his life was
spent helping others learn to be safe as
Fritz worked as a fire safety inspector
for a quarter century which led to his
first bits of dabbling and taking by
finding antiques related to firefighting
like his friend well Fritz also has a
passion for motorcycles having bought
his first harley-davidson as a teenager
these days he frequently attends the
same Sturgis Motorcycle Rally and at one
point was president of the Davenport
American bikers aimed toward education
chapter and even gave motorcycle safety
lessons as well he finally got into the
pickin business full-time when he opened
the shop Frank for its signs in 2002
which is still in Savannah Illinois he
and Wolfe kept crossing paths and
eventually both men started tagging
together professionally and filming
their Expo
leading into the American ticker show
Danielle Colby Cushman a constant
presence minding the store in LeClair
while wolf and Fritz are out exploring
their next big item with the occasional
picking trip thrown in the mix here and
there Danielle Colby Cushman is also a
formidable presence on the show born on
December 3rd 1975 Colby was raised in a
family of Jehovah's Witnesses but her
interests became a lot more varied
outside of the group she's also an
accomplished burlesque dancer to the
point that she's toured around the
country under the name Johnny diesel a
name she's had since childhood founded
her own troupe for Alaska mustache and
opened her own dance school in Chicago
Danny Diesel's bump-and-grind Academy
she's also a former roller derby girl a
hobby that spanned three years until
injuries put an end to it Lauren Rae
Grisham's one of the managers of the
Pickers Nashville outpost Lauren ray
Grisham also got into the pickin
business early through her explorations
of old abandoned farmhouses in her
hometown of Athens Alabama working a
pawn shop with her dad and touring
antique stores with her mom when it came
time to get her college education
Grisham moved to Tennessee out near
Nashville before she fell in with the
thicker --zz Grisham had been serving a
stint with manual the famed rhinestone
loving costume designer who's made
clothing for rock stars country legends
presidents and even Salvador Dali
however she decided she wanted a big new
project and the tickers just happened to
be expanding their antique archeology
business into Nashville setting up shop
inside a former car factory she joined
the team in 2011 and has been the top
representative of the Pickers southern
branch ever since Robbie Wolfe Mike's
brother Robbie Wolfe is occasionally
seen on the show working to help the
Pickers especially fulfilling since he
shares an interest with Mike and old
vehicles so Robbie prefers automobiles
to motorcycles however when he's not out
with his brother and the rest of the
Pickers crew
Robbie is back in Davenport where he's
been running his landscaping company
r.j. wolf and son which he founded in
the 90s and is still running to this day
they offer an impressively varied list
of services including full installation
footing index gating driveways new and
all [ __ ] up lighting creating outdoor
living spaces and more if you're near
Iowa and you like
Robbi wolf can fix up your yard and buy
some junk from you
win-win thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to